a baby's t-shirt requires four-fifths
yards of fabric or four-fifths of a yard
of fabric how many t-shirts can be made
from 48 yards so we want to do is we
essentially want to say how many groups
of four-fifths of a yard can we make
with 48 yards so you literally view this
as we want to take 48 yards so we want
to take 48 yards and divide it into
groups of four-fifths
of a yard and say how many groups are
there because each of those groups can
make one baby's t-shirt if you give me
four-fifths of a yard one baby's t-shirt
so the number of groups of four-fifths
is the number of babies t-shirts now
when we divide by a fraction we just
have to remember that that is the same
thing that is completely equivalent to
multiplying to multiplying times the
reciprocal of the fraction so if we have
four-fifths here that will be five
over four the reciprocal now the still
might say hey i have a whole number here
and a fraction you just have to remember
any whole number can be written as a
fraction this is the same thing as 48
over 1
times
5 over 4. now we could just multiply it
out at this point figure out what 48
times 5 is and that'll be over 4 but
that'll get big numbers and it'll be
hard to kind of divide and all that but
we could divide at this stage right here
we could divide the numerator and the
denominator by 4 or we could say look
this is going to be equal to
48 times 5 whatever that is
over 4. now let's divide the numerator
by 4 well we could divide 48 by 4 and we
will get 12 and we could whatever we did
the numerator we have to do the
denominator so if we divide 4 by 4 we
get 1. so then we're left with 12 times
5 which is equal to
12 times 5 which is equal to 60
over 1 which is the exact same thing as
60. so you can actually make
children's or babies t-shirts from 48
yards if each of them use four-fifths of
a yard